Spreen agent or Janowski NB insider ESPN
the woge pod terrific writer hi watch hi
Chris how are you whoa Jen B all-star
teams were announced last night I guess
the only quibble I had with any of them
was Trey young in that starting slot I
bought for Kyle Lowry Ben Simmons
certainly in the mix when you I mean
when you think about who's an all-star
who's not how much does team's success
factor in for someone like you yeah I
think that's the hardest that's the
hardest measure because you know Bradley
feels another player like and not
necessarily would would not as him as a
starter but you know he's on that
Wizards team that you you know he made
that decision to stay and re-sign but
this is an elite player in the league I
think the coaches certainly you know I
think that's as much of a factor for
them is anyone I think they'd like to
reward players on winning teams and I
think you see that you know with what
you'll see with the reserves but listen
at the end of the day to me all NBA is
what really matters when you want to
define when you sort of put your mark in
history of really who is the best player
in that season I think it's more
measured by all-nba the all-star games
an exhibition and if people want to see
Trey young dribble the ball through
people's legs and and and and making 35
footers then let people see Trey young
that's how I view it because it's just
an exhibition game that by the way as
we've seen like a lot of guys will do
what they can to get names and then get
out of the game yeah I have no problem
with that
in fact if that's the case I'd say just
go back to a hundred percent of the fan
voting and let them get let them sell
Minako false start it's fine you know
I I agree listen to me there is not much
that is left just for the fans anymore I
have no problem with it being 100
percent fan voting let people see who
they want to see if they want to see
Allen Iverson play until he's 38 years
old in the all-star game
let him see AI play they wanted to see
the Grady play
so the end of his career even when he
wasn't an all-star let him see him play
yeah I'm with you on that one
ah you were in New Orleans on Wednesday
night for Zions debut had him on your
podcast afterwards your impressions of
your the Zions first NBA appearance I
mean it was that three four minutes
stretch and the fourth quarter was it
was electrifying I mean that building I
mean I thought the roof was going to
come off and you know it's pretty rare
when you know when a moment lives up to
there was so much anticipation for that
for that debut and to see him you know
get a stretch of time there scoring 17th
straight and and reminding people why
you know this was a player who is the
number one overall pick I thought you
know he's just different and and he said
it to me after the game like I'm one of
one I'm unique and the body type and how
he looks it I think you you have to
train your eyes a little bit for
something that is different than
anything we've seen before and and you
know I know but you know Alvin Gentry
said to me after I asked them you know
for comparable when he's putting an
offense in and he's trying to figure out
how to use this player to you know to
maximize that team and you know he
mentioned Berkeley is like the one
comparison now they don't necessarily
play you know Berkeley became a better
shooter as time went on but I I just
think this is a winning player and this
is a guy you saw it in college and I
know it was just a preseason but you
know you could see the way he can get to
the rim he can finish and this is going
to be a player who you know over time
with that young core they have in New
Orleans that has a chance to be a pretty
good team when you talk to the pelicans
front office people how concerning is it
that he has so much weight at his upper
body and at some point there's only so
much you can do to kind of prevent that
type of weight from coming crashing down
on those knees
that me in particular every single time
he goes above the rim well you know I
think it's part of the regimen they put
him through while he was out which was
changing the way changing the way he
landed changing the way he runs and and
I think for him there's no question he's
got to keep that weight down he was
probably you looked at him the other
night he's probably around I I think
just under 300 I know that they've
listed about 285 it might be a little
more than that and but you know it's
again he is a player who you know there
have been great players in this league
who carried a lot of weight and that
there's there's no question about it
it's just it's a different body type and
but there's no question for New Orleans
you know keeping trying to find a
program and a regimen that keeps him on
the floor that keeps them healthy is you
know that's kind of paramount to what
they've been trying to do and and it's
part of why he was out so long I mean I
think the knee the meniscus was healed
and healthy and they wanted to make sure
that when they put him back on the floor
he was gonna be the position to be able
to stay on the floor find a job or
Janowski ESPN NBA Insider hosted the
watch pod joining us here Dan Patrick
show about two weeks away watch from the
trade deadline in the NBA give me the
most interesting team or player that
you're tracking the closest right now
well I said III think that you know New
Orleans and going back to them will be
interesting I mean drew holidays a
player who listen they may revisit
something again with him between now and
February 6 I think now they're trying to
see what this team looks like with Zion
there would be a great deal there is a
great deal of interest in holiday around
the league but he's under contract for
multiple years I don't have to do
anything with them and New Orleans plan
has been to just play a few games here
with Zion see see what it looks like you
know I think the market is especially
for
guys who've been all-stars like the
Kevin love's and the Andre Drummond's I
think the markets lean for them I don't
get a sense there's a great appetite
with giving away a really good
first-round picks for players in this in
this grouping I think you can see a lot
of stuff around the edges Chris I I
don't think there's gonna be you know
there you know how it is on February 6th
like between you know noon and 3:00 p.m.
you know there's nine to twelve trades
or 10 to 14 trades and I think a lot of
them are going to be around the edges
and you know I'd rate with dollar is
still out there and you know actually
we've got him in studio on Friday on
tonight at ESPN and countdown and I
think it Memphis has believed all along
they would find a deal for him and I
think they've talked it they certainly
talked to teams in both conferences but
if he gets past February 6 and they get
a buyout you know that becomes releasing
to me the buyout market could be
potentially very interesting Darren
Collison who is is a free agent not a
buyout player you know he has been
strongly considering returning to play
and Collison has been focused on doing
that in LA and both the Lakers and
Clippers would love to have him yeah
watching the Lakers last night the game
in Boston notwithstanding they're
playing good basketball LeBron is
playing at a high level Anthony Davis
back in the lineup but the question of
Kyle coos must still kind of lingers out
there if he's the right fit alongside
LeBron and AD and that kind of third
star type of role what do you gather as
the Lakers position on Kyle cusion over
the next couple of weeks I think they've
been listening for quite a while on him
but Chris the hard part of trading him
and you know this he makes two million
dollars a year and you've got to stack
up contracts to make numbers work
because we assume if you're training him
for an established player who you think
can help you win right now and the
Lakers are absolutely in win now moded
to seem over the next couple years it's
a player who's making a lot of money
whether it's you know 12 16 18 20
and how much of your deaths do you have
to tread away to make the money work on
a deal you know you have DeMarcus
Cousins contract sitting there you can
look at the roster and look at some of
the names of what they make and and try
to figure out a way to you know stack up
contracts to meet the money of the
player you're bringing back and I think
that's as much as anything is the hard
part of trading Kuzma because he hasn't
he hasn't signed his rookie extension
yet before let's go I'm watching the
Trailblazers play last night and look
they lose to Dallas and it's kind of a
red alert time for poor them because
they get the next eight games against
playoff teams the ninth being a trip to
New Orleans to play Zion and the
pelicans been disappointing all season
four for Portland they've had some
injury issues but do you get the sense
they're gonna kind of ride this whole
thing out and try to reboot it next year
or could they be active going into the
week from Thursday yeah I don't know
that there's I don't think there's a hey
let's save our season move to the
Blazers I don't think that makes sense
for them especially if they have to
sacrifice something long-term
and you said listener kitc is practicing
again they expect to have him back
and you know I think getting you know
listen they had so much size in the
preseason right and then the injury
Turkish goes down you know they lose you
know they lost a lot of frontcourt size
and talent and it became all of a sudden
you know a really small team but this is
a team who next year you know you bring
everybody back you know that young group
of Simon's and little or a year older I
think this is still a core that you know
can you know can be really competitive
in the Western Conference but I I just
think that the injuries have devastated
them this year but what you do have to
admire about the organization and
certainly Dame Lillard at the top is is
like they don't want to take a mulligan
on it like he wants to he wants to do
everything he can to try to get that HD
I don't think they'll get there but it's
a very competitive organization they've
been in the playoffs now for
you know how many straight years is it
Chris maybe 78 years they've been in the
postseason so the dart many of that
there are many streaks like that around
the league anymore
no no question hey Jordan a ski it's
been in the insider woods pod former
editor of the vertical - can you get
ESPN to a 30 for 30 on the vertical
would love to do that the highlights
could just be you know Bobby marks
waving in front of a touchscreen and Tom
Crean saying tyler lydon stinks like we
could just hey always good to talk to
you which appreciate the time all right
doc you stood at sage for danowsky MB
insider over at ESPN for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]